russian opposition leader alexey navalny
has arrived in russia
after spending nearly five months in
germany recovering
after being poisoned by a nerve agent
moments ago he was a border control
where he spoke with border police
he then kissed his wife goodbye and
walked
off with those police it's been
confirmed that he has been
detained in the last hour the valley's
plane was diverted to another airport in
moscow just before it was expected to
land
russia's prison authority had warned
that he would be arrested if he returned
the opposition figure blames the russian
government for his poisoning but the
kremlin
has denied any involvement let's go live
now to moscow
alexandra godfoir is there for us
alexandra what's the latest
well as you said uh the navalny
apparently has been detained by the
border police
he kissed his wife goodbye they did not
allow him
his lawyer to that accompanied him from
berlin
to join him so he's been taken away by
the police
in the meantime people that were flying
with him including his wife
across the russian border and are now on
the
airport there has been a warrant issued
recently
on navalny because the prison
authorities here are claiming that he
violated
his probation period by not
reporting to them and that they did not
know his
whereabouts in past months uh during the
flight navalny did not communicate with
a lot of journalists that were following
him uh on the plane itself
but after he entered the building of the
airport to which he was diverted
he said that this that he's very happy
and that this is
the best day of his life in the last
five months that for him it was never
a question whether he's going to return
to russia or not that russia is his
homeland
and then he said maybe what is the
crucial of
this whole day and the message that he
actually wanted to send to everybody in
russia is
and that is that he is not afraid and
that he advises everybody else
not to be afraid the supporters of
navain gathered in another airport where
he was
supposed to land uh today before the
flight was uh diverted
um they've been they've been arrested
there more than 30 people
we we here were arrested there and this
diversion is presumably done
exactly to avoid him being
greeted by people who support him
and what's likely to happen to navalny
now
well indeed if this uh warrant uh that
was issued by the prison authorities
goes through he will be uh processed and
sent
to first detention center there is uh
from this prison authorities
a plea to the court to decide
that navalny had indeed violated his
probation
in which case if the court decides
something like this
would mean that he would have to serve
the three and a half years real sentence
that was decided in 2014. this
is very problematic since his probation
period
actually expired on the 30th of december
now
by the paper documents or paper trailers
you would call it uh the
uh this prison authorities submitted
this request on the last day basically
29th of december it's a question whether
a court will take this uh into account
this of course is viewed as fabricated
is viewed as a way to pressurize him
further
and whilst he was in germany uh there is
other charges that have been brought and
that is for instance a charge
that he allegedly embezzled uh his own
fund his organization called fund
to fight um the corruption um of course
he says that this is all
ridiculous uh accusations that are not
based on truth but on the wish
of the authorities and of the kremlin to
uh uh to basically
disable him in in doing his political
activity
uh and being an oppositional politician
here in russia
alexandra garfield reporting live there
from moscow alexandra
uh many thanks indeed just want to show
you some live pictures uh from
uh moscow's shut up and dievo airport uh
this is uh alexis navalny's wife
uh cutting rather a despondent figure
after
seeing her husband walking away with
those police officers of course this was
not the airport at which they'd
planned to land so there's no one there
to
greet her so she
is probably wondering what's going to
happen next uh
let's bring in uh daryl mcdougall who is
principal russia analyst
at the global risk consultancy various
maplecroft he joins us now live via
skype
uh from london uh dollar what do you
make of this circus this is a man who
skipped
a probation appointment one could argue
within reason and yet we've had this
huge security presence
first of all at one airport then a plane
being diverted and him landing at
another airport
him being refused entry to russia and
then
police taking him away what do you make
of it all
well last uh december we saw
putin who still refuses to say navalny's
name
um kind of dismissed the idea that the
security services would even be
interested in such a man
um saying who is he he's not terribly
important
uh the events today have shown us that
that's not the case that the kremlin
is um quite concerned um about
his uh potential as a political leader
and a
organizer and mobilizer of the
opposition
um you know the security theater at uh
uh the last minute uh running the of the
flights
uh this shows that they see this man as
a threat and
the question is what are they going to
do about it and that's something where
they they might be a little bit more
divided
why the question has to ask why did
navalny
uh he's in so much danger there's always
been
there's already been this threat upon
his life why did he insist
on going back when he knew that he was
going to be detained
well that's a question for from mr
navalny in terms of his exact
uh reasoning but um if he were to remain
in exile effectively in germany
um his ability to influence russian
politics or be a political actor
um would be nil now he could you know
potentially live a reasonably
comfortable life in
exile but he has made the decision that
he
you know this is his path this is what
he um
he wants to do the his mission he's
committed to and um
i think we just have to to to respect
that he's a remarkably brave individual
um in terms of his willingness to do
this given the inevitability of him
being detained
when he arrived and the the potential
for
for future harm being done to him
germany has passed
to russia various documents including
transcriptive interviews with navalny
after his poisoning the kremlin still
refuses to conduct
an investigation into that that
poisoning will these documents from
germany make any difference
no uh the decision not to conduct an
investigation is essentially a political
one
and is one designed to show the impunity
of the kremlin
um and the impunity of the the security
agencies there's no real doubt as to
what happened to
mr navalny in august
and you know by not even mounting a
token investigation
um as was the case with when uh barista
himself was assassinated in 2015 the
kremlin is sending a very clear message
um that you know this this was something
that was
uh almost certainly sanctioned by the
political leadership
um and trying to send a message to
navalny and supporters and also indeed
the west
um there's very little that germany can
do or that any western state can do
to make the kremlin reverse course on
this point
um and the likelihood of a genuine
investigation is effectively milled
given the
involvement of the security services um
in the attempted assassination in the
first place
okay can can germany though or the
international community
uh at large bring any pressure to bear
on russia
over the treatment of alexia navalny
i mean there's a limited number of
options uh that are still on the table
given that we're
several years into a sanctions regime
that started with the
uh the magnitsky act that was
significantly escalated following the
invasion of ukraine
um you know russia has learned to to
live with these sanctions
and putin has certainly demonstrated in
his approach to the incoming
biden administration that he doesn't
expect
an improvement in relations and isn't
really going to expend much political
energy in trying to
to achieve this uh the one area where we
could see
significant costs inflicted on the
kremlin
for further persecution of navalny is
over the nord stream two pipeline
which germany and other european states
have moved to protect even
giving us opposition and opposition
within the european union itself
um and that could be you know
that could be an area where they can
again impose real costs but the question
is whether the kremlin is willing to
accept those costs
in order to sideline or otherwise get
rid of
a political actor in regards as to
threatening
good to talk to you again dara many
thanks indeed donald duel there in
london
thank you